THIS
US.THOWG  HOUR, T OF THE ARTIS
I.OOKING A
KACE CENTER
WHERE THROS ON TCH PADERN
TH AO-.
TH
ENDATION? I
SART EA
NO OFFICIASCST YAS REAL FEINEVIC
SAID WE T
O-GO FORSTILTO FIND
IF THE LAUNCDISHE'S EW RIGHT NO.
OK
LET MEREPROBLEM YOU, SARA.
SY Y  OU  CAPN
GETSFFAUTS TE , Y, IF THIS THINE
CKET
TH R
GEE ON THE CE OF TCKET.
NGO THD YDROGE G
ER NHRENHEIT.
BUT RIGHT AROUND HERE EYE  LINED
BID
TRTOE  AND OME UPITH ONE SO
EXNDMET,E ING          INHOIQ,
TH H BEEN TRNG RESEAT THISBUT S
UNSUCCESSFUL.
TULY, T
GOTTEN THEFFICIAL WORDE AUNCH M
INDEED
SO NOW, THCONEXTWHEN CANAGNCIS
ALLY TRY TO
TH
Y  FIXESF TIME.
THEYVER LAUNCHNDAY.THATHER LAUNA
ENTIREL FEF  PUTBACKECRAE THIS
UNTIL LATE SEPR RLIN
BE TMENTION,A T.ANY TIMEOU LAND.
NGATY
SES THE LIKEODT
SE CAN GO WRON
RA KRISTLOVE GKI
IS BEECENTEREL
I'M ACTUALLY VERY JEALOUS THAT .
T S IN
OTTHAUEN
NGLAS ROCKET FORYSN
BEEBUT WED REMINDTHIS IS AN IM
EVENTUALLY THEY CAN O AND WE HA
PR TS UNMANNEDN. DISTMENT, AT
HIS.LOVEA DEKNOW Y HE TO BSA TOO
ITERFECTHING.
THERE TPLYOU.
REO WE'V TO GENDAC SLSMODEL.
E FOR A BIT LONGER T.D.
AS YOU, IS
TING F CONFENC
A PRESS CONFERENCE THA